vamos a intentar otra integral de
superficie y la superficie que vamos a
tomar en este caso es el exterior de
esta figura que tenemos aquí que que
podemos descomponer en tres distintas
superficies la primera de ellas es la
base que es esencialmente un círculo y
de radio no es decir es el el círculo
unitario rellenito la segunda que
tenemos aquí en azul
es digamos un cilindro es un cilindro
que tiene como base de este mismo
círculo unitario que ha sido cortado
además de todo por un plano y el plano
por el cual éste estamos realizando el
corte es el plano z igual a 1 - x es
este el plano esencialmente digo el
plano puede ser mucho más grande pero
solo nos estamos quedando con la tapa
que es donde digamos el interior oeste
este subconjunto que queda dentro del
cilindro ok entonces este esta
superficie así es como la descomponemos
como
superficies digamos ajenas y lo que
queremos calcular es la integral de la
función zeta sobre esta superficie
entonces esencialmente lo que podemos
hacer es vamos a seguir con el color que
tenemos para la integral la integral de
nuestra función zeta de s
esta integral sobre esta superficie la
podemos descomponer como la suma de tres
integrales esto es la integral de zeta
de s sobre la superficie s uno más
la integral de zeta de s sobre la
superficie 2 más
la integral sobre la receta de s sobre
la superficie 3 entonces esta integral
original la de la descomponemos en tres
integrales y que es lo que tendrían uno
que hacer bueno pues tendría uno que
parametrizar cada una de estas tres
superficies y resolver cada una de forma
independiente entonces vamos a empezar
con esta primera que es la más sencilla
y uno estaría tentado se antoja digamos
parametrizar ese uno que es el círculo
unitario pero hay que notar algo cuánto
vale z en este conjunto ese uno en el
círculo unitario el círculo unitario
sólo está formado por puntos x sigue
porque está en el plano xy quiere decir
que la altura es cero entonces para
todos estos puntos z vale cero por lo
tanto si tenemos la integral de cero
sobre cualquier conjunto esto
simplemente nos da que todo esto vale
cero entonces uno al inicio a lo mejor
podría decir bueno pues vamos a
parametrizar
el círculo unitario está entre este
cierto conjunto de parámetros en fin
podría uno estar tentado a hacer eso
pero siempre es mejor revisar si las
cosas pueden simplificarse sin tener que
hacer tantas operaciones entonces ahora
lo que prosigue es parametrizar nuestra
superficie s2 ok entonces parámetros
hemos s 2 s 2 s 2 esencialmente es el
cilindro que son los puntos digamos de
la frontera de nuestro círculo unitario
que esos los podemos parametrizar muy
bien y hay que sumarle cierta altura
variable verdad entonces si son puntos
de la frontera de nuestro círculo
unitario eso ya lo podemos ya lo podemos
parametrizar es decir x es igual a con
coordenadas polares sería el radio por
el coseno de del ángulo pero el radio es
1 entonces sólo nos queda el coseno del
ángulo que es y entonces
si lo que está midiendo es el ángulo el
ángulo que estamos
midiendo para ir recorriendo está este
círculo que va a ser el seno de ese
ángulo seno de v donde ahora sólo hay
que decir que se mueve entre 0 y 2 pi
para que le dé toda la vuelta verdad
entonces ahora sólo nos falta decir
quién es z bueno se está digamos que es
b es otro parámetro digamos z lo que me
va midiendo es la altura y z se mueve
pues sí sí la base es el círculo
unitario que está en el plano x pues z
se mueve o más bien b se mueve en 30 y
el techo pero el techo ahora a
diferencia de los casos que hemos hecho
es variable verdad porque no es la misma
altura de este lado que de este lado
entonces también sabemos que es zeta
z la altura se mueve entre la base que
es 0 y este plano que es 1 x es decir 0
es menor o igual que z que es menor o
igual que 1 - x entonces si ves z b se
va a mover entre 0 y 1 - x pero x es
coseno dv entonces este techo o digamos
la la cota superior que decimos que ve
se mueve entre 0 y 1 - x donde x es
coseno coseno de eeuu entonces esto y es
variable a diferencia de los de los
otros ejemplos entonces ahora vamos a
calcular de ese para esta superficie y
sabemos que de ese es la norma o la
magnitud del de eeuu la derivada de
respecto perdón la derivada de r
respecto de v cruz la derivada de r
respecto de b y sacamos la norma o la
magnitud de eso
dv dv pero entonces aquí es donde está
dada la parametrización sólo que no lo
escrito en
como una función vectorial que depende
de dos parámetros de verdad
esencialmente sí quién lo puedo hacer
digamos de este lado o sea nuestro
nuestro vector r2 digamos r2 porque
estamos en la superficie 2 va a ser en
la primera coordenada es coseno de eeuu
que multiplica el vector y más el seno
de v que multiplica el vector jota es
éste más b que multiplica al vector k
entonces quién va a ser
hereu pues es derivar esto respecto de
la derivada de coseno dvs menos
dv
por iu
la derivada del seno es coseno de v por
jota y la derivada de b es cero entonces
podría no ponerlo pero déjenme ponerlo
para que sea más claro cuando tomemos el
producto cruz
y ahora vamos a tomar la derivada de r
respecto de b si nos damos cuenta en la
primera y en la segunda coordenada 9
entonces va a ser cero y más 0 jota más
la derivada de ver respecto debe pues
simplemente es 1 que queda multiplicando
al vector k entonces aquí ya tenemos
nuestras y nuestros vectores derivada
digamos y ya podemos calcular muy bien
quién es el producto cruz de eeuu cruz
rb
porque eso simplemente déjenme de
hacerlo bien
esto es hereu cruz rd simplemente es un
determinante es el determinante
este determinante donde ponemos a los
vectores canónicos y j y k ok
y después ponemos las coordenadas en eso
me salió bastante chueco ahí está
después ponemos las coordenadas de
nuestros vectores derivada entonces las
coordenadas del primero simplemente es
menos seno de un coseno de eeuu
0 y las del segundo simplemente son 0 0
entonces como ven el determinante va a
ser algo muy sencillo de calcular muy
sencillo tomamos primero y quitamos
columna y y renglón y nos queda el
determinante de este pedazo que
simplemente es coseno de v por i
ahora tenemos menos - j quitamos la el
renglón y la columna y nos queda el
determinante de estos cuatro que es
menos seno de por uno menos cero por
cero que es cero entonces nos queda
menos
con este menos se hace más seno de eeuu
por jota y luego con acá quitamos el
renglón y la columna y nos queda menos
seno de eeuu por 00 -0 por coseno de
buques cero entonces aquí va un cero acá
muy bien entonces ahora si tomamos la
magnitud de esto simplemente esto es
bastante sencillo verdad porque la
magnitud de eeuu cruz
rb simplemente es la raíz cuadrada va a
ser la raíz cuadrada de cada una de sus
coordenadas al cuadrado y lo sumamos
verdad entonces va a ser coseno cuadrado
de u
ahora este que es seno cuadrado de 10 al
cuadrado que es 0 y esto es muy sencillo
porque coseno cuadrado de un seno
cuadrado de v es la la identidad
trigonométricas más sencilla esto es 1 y
si sacamos la raíz cuadrada de 1 esto es
1 entonces cómo ven la la de ese es muy
sencilla ahora que ya estamos ahora ya
estamos prácticamente listos para
calcular la integral pero ya se me está
terminando el tiempo así que lo haremos
en el próximo vídeo